today I'm going to find out with curator
Selina Hurley how a bed and a bicycle
led to the creation of the Paralympics
and another story from the stores I
recognized Stoke Mandeville from the
Olympics on I'm guessing I know what
this is but do you not tell me yes so
basically what it is it's a bed cycle
and it was developed at Stoke Mandeville
Hospital by someone called and literally
government who you can see his name and
just there and and he developed ideas
that rehabilitation after an injury or
particularly after war injuries should
include like physical and emotional and
kind of work so it's basically a bicycle
turned on its side yeah so it's made of
lots of different bicycle parts we have
the handles here so you would pedal with
your hands here or you would pedal with
your feet as well and there's actually a
little speedometer here so you can see
how fast you're going and you can set
how long you would be going for there's
also a gear so you can actually change
the tension like you would on an
exercise there's a lot of big kind of
twisty physical things on this yeah so
what did this turn into over time and so
we know that this one was actually still
used till 1994 and really like the chase
Lee Trust who donated it to the museum
and there's obviously lots of different
physio kind of exercises now that
hydrotherapy as well but you still have
forms of exercise bikes that you use
today but you can just imagine what it
would be like to lie down either on this
bed or have this rolled over your bed
for your daily exercise and whether you
wanted to do or not and stoke mandeville
went on to start the Paralympics is that
right it did so and there was the the
use of hold and annual games a selectman
one which was developed by lubed
equipment and his staff and and the
eighth version of that games kind of
turns into the first Paralympic Games so
we have a great object that to tell some
really personal stories but also has
this much bigger link to the Paralympic
movement
[Music]
you